Você sabia que uma vitamina simples pode
reduzir em mais da metade o risco de
novos cânceres de pele? Olha só o que a
ciência descobriu sobre a niacinamida,
uma forma de B3. Pois é, estudos
recentes publicados no Jama New England
Journal of Medicine mostraram algo
impressionante. Tomar 500 mg de
niacinamida, forma de vitamina B3 duas
vezes ao dia, reduziu em 23% os novos
carcinomas de pele. Mas sabe o mais
interessante? Se você já teve um câncer
de pele e começa a tomar depois disso, a
proteção sobe para 54%.
é um número muito significativo. Veja
bem, a níacinamida trabalha restaurando
os níveis de nada demais nas células da
pele, que é fundamental pro reparo do
DNA danificado pelo sol. Ela também
controla inflamação, melhora a função
mitocondrial e fortalece a barreira
cutânea. E o melhor de tudo, diferente
da neacina comum, ela não causa aquela
vermelhidão no rosto, não tem efeitos
colaterais relevantes e é super bem
tolerada mesmo em idosos que tomam
vários remédios. Então, se você tem
histórico de câncer de pele ou muita
exposição solar, vale conversar sobre
essa estratégia preventiva baseada em
evidências sólidas. Yeah.